so as we get into Secret Wars number
three keep in mind that we're going to
be running over these as the release to
us and so we may find that there are
relatively large gaps between each
telling of this story but what we're
going to find in this portion of the
story is we're going to receive a large
bit of information regarding the origin
of battleworld having said that in
Secret Wars number two if you recall we
were given this sort of tour of battle
world and that we learned that the Thor
Corps is composed of alternate verses of
Thor and individuals from alternate
realities that were deemed worthy of
wielding Thor's hammer and that the Thor
Corps itself basically functions as the
police force of this new battle world
now but we also learned was that Doctor
Doom had apparently constructed
battleworld
although we weren't really told how this
was done but due to the vast power that
he seems to possess doom operates as the
ruler of battle world as a God with
Doctor Strange
I guess acting as the sheriff and
second-in-command to Doctor Doom what we
also learned was that under doom are a
series of Barons with each ruling their
own section of battle world under their
own authority although there is some
measure of what they can and can't do
now at the end of the last story if you
recall we discovered that the life raft
used by the ultimate universe to escape
the collapse of their of the multiverse
was discovered and accidentally opened
resulting in Thanos Maximus the mad
neighbor the Submariner and the rest of
the Cabal basically escaping and getting
out into battle world proper now from
here we jump to Doctor Strange as he
investigates the wrath if Thanos and the
Cabal emerge from and after speaking
with several members of the Thor Corps
Doctor Strange tells them to basically
search out and define the cabal but to
bring them back alive what we also find
is that Doctor Strange realizes that not
everyone who was on board the raft left
with Thanos revealing that Miles Morales
had actually stowed away and didn't seem
to be detected by the cabal themselves
in addition to this as miles begins to
explain how it was he came to be on the
raft
Doctor Strange actually stops him once
he realizes that Miles Morales remembers
everything before and during the
collapse of the multiverse
now from here we transition to Doctor
Strange the newest Thor recruit and
Miles Morales inside of what's referred
to as the hidden aisle of automotive
which is to say dr. Strange's own
territory that's hidden away from the
eyes of everybody else presumably with
the exception of Doctor Doom what we're
told here is that Doctor Strange was
actually able to preserve elements of
the main Marvel Universe version of the
planet Earth within his own sanctum
sanctorum but that he's also in
possession of the wrath that was used by
the heroes of the main Marvel Universe
to escape the collapse of the multiverse
and after Thor is able to actually open
the raft at the request of Doctor
Strange the group is initially greeted
by Peter Parker Carol Danvers Jane
Foster Thor and star-lord now the
initial response by both Doctor Strange
and the remnants of the earth-616
superheroes is one of skepticism and
that they don't know if they can trust
the others or not but when the group is
actually joined by Scott Summers as the
Phoenix Black Panther and Reed Richards
Doctor Strange becomes convinced that
these are indeed his friends and so what
we do is we get this sort of explanation
from Doctor Strange with regards to how
it was
that battleworld came into existence
what Doctor Strange tells them is that
they've all been in stasis inside this
raft for about eight years or so and
that when the multiverse collapsed doom
began reaching out to what was left of
the multiverse and began rounding up
various pieces of those earths to form
battleworld now keep in mind as Doctor
Strange is giving this explanation he's
not actually referring to Doctor Doom
he's simply referring to this being as
God now in addition to this no one on
battle world with the exception of a
handful of people have any idea of what
their past universe was like or that it
even existed as far as they're concerned
they basically just came into existence
with battleworld and the reason why they
believe this is because quite literally
dr. doom had modified their memories now
when Reed Richards asked the question
who this God is this is when Doctor
Strange reveals that is Victor Von Doom
that dr. doom had effectively saved all
of their lives now from here we switch
back to the Cabal as they continue to
figure out this new world and
as the group basically kind of sits
around and they kind of eat and they
debate and so on the consensus among
those talking is that they should not
have killed all the versions of Thor and
instead they should have basically
questioned those members of the Thor
core who are present but the result is
that Thanos respond so I simply say they
will have all the answers they seek that
they seek shortly and when the questions
asked how it is at Thanos knows this
panel simply says that that he's looking
up and so what this basically tells us
is that before court as it was assigned
by Doctor Strange to track down the
Cabal has successfully done so and it
seems as though the Thor core is
basically descending on Thanos and his
cabal and this is where the story ends
we're kind of left to find out what
happens next and issue number four but
that being said we're gonna go ahead and
read this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and that will catch you guys later peace